und damit können wir schon mal auf dem
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es um einen antrag der
linksfraktion mit dem titel
schulschließungen verhindern die
fraktion möchte ebenso wie der titel
sagt verhindern dass wieder schulen
geschlossen werden im letzten block da
und waren zwischenzeitlich
40.000 schulen und 58.000 kitas
geschlossen über die folgen auch die
psychischen folgen werden wir wohl noch
in zukunft diskutieren und die
linksfraktion hat nun in ihrem antrag
einige maßnahmen vorgelegt was eben
diese schulschließung verhindern kann
unter anderem forderte sie kostenlose
fb2 oder medizinische masten sie fordert
antike schnelltests und ausreichend
desinfektionsmittel aber auch
niedrigschwellige angebote oder
kostenlose tests bei verdachtsfällen
außerdem schlägt die linksfraktion vor
dass es an zusätzlichen orten auch der
unterricht stattfinden kann zb in museen
theatern oder
bibliotheken als erste rednerin wird
sich auch eine linken-politikerin zu
diesem antrag äußern bzw vorstellen das
ist auch nicole gohlke aus der
linksfraktion
die
aussenpolitiker werden jetzt hier den
saal verlassen wie sie sehen so dass es
jetzt
dann noch kurz zur ruhe kommen falls sie
sich gewundert haben immer haben die
abgeordneten auch nochmal darüber
abgestimmt ob auch der zweite antrag der
fdp-fraktion
grenzgebiet bohlen belarus ob der eben
jetzt auch gleich abgestimmt wird oder
erst einmal in den hauptausschuss kommt
zur weiteren beratung auch da haben sich
die abgeordneten wie beim ersten antrag
dafür ausgesprochen dass dieser antrag
erst einmal im hauptausschuss auch
beraten wird darf ich sie bitten platz
zu nehmen gespräch über anderes zu
führen liebe spd kollegen in der zweiten
reihe
ich würde gern beginnen
und da sagen sie es ihren kollegen
so ich halte die debatte ich gebe das
wort für die fraktion die linke nicole
gohlke
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die linke hat heute den antrag
vorgelegt kita und schulschließungen
verhindern mehr tempo bei
schutzmaßnahmen für kinder und
jugendliche weil wir sehenden auges auf
eine erneute bildungskatastrophe zu
steuern obwohl sie abgewendet werden
könnte und das darf auf keinen fall
passieren
die geschäftsführende alte
bundesregierung verschleppt das thema
wieder mal und die designierte neue
ampelkoalition ist hier bislang untätig
und bei allem verständnis für die
schwierige gemengelage zu beginn einer
neuen regierung aber kolleginnen
kollegen jetzt ist nicht der zeitpunkt
sich mit lösungen zeit zu lassen jetzt
ist der zeitpunkt um familien und
schulen zu zeigen dass alles getan wird
um kinder und jugendliche zu schützen
und die bildungseinrichtungen möglichst
offen zu halten jetzt ist dieser
zeitpunkt ist bereits von platz zwölf
wir wissen doch alle die kita und
schulschließungen bernd der letzten
eineinhalb jahre pandemie haben die
familien an der rand an den rand ihrer
belastungsgrenze gebracht die
psychischen folgen dieser eingreifenden
maßnahmen sind immens und umso schlimmer
ist es für die familien jetzt am beginn
oder eigentlich schon mitten in der
vierten stelle jeden tag erneut zu
zittern ob ihnen so ein szenario wieder
droht darauf braucht es jetzt dringend
antworten
unternehmen verschärft sich die soziale
spaltung und auch das kann man doch
nicht einfach so laufen lassen gerade
kinder von alleinerziehenden von eltern
die im schichtdienst arbeiten oder die
in beengten wohnverhältnissen leben die
drohen jetzt nochmal weiter abgehängt zu
werden wenn wir das nicht verhindern die
menschen haben ein recht darauf dass da
endlich mal wirklich gegengesteuert wird
aber sommer und sommer und ferien und
ferien verstreichen und die
bundesregierung nichts das ist ein
schlag ins gesicht der familien kollegin
politik
viele bildungseinrichtungen sind für den
drohenden corona winter nicht gewappnet
und benötigen unverzüglich eine pandemie
gerechte ausstattung und es ist ja schön
dass ich hier anscheinend alle
fraktionen angeblich einig sind dass die
bildungseinrichtungen möglichst offen
gehalten werden sollen aber warum
passiert denn da nichts luftfilter
kommen nicht in den schulen an es gibt
keine ideen für zusätzliche räume für
kleinere lerngruppen nichts wurde
unternommen um endlich mehr fachkräfte
zu gewinnen und die tablets und laptops
die so essenziell sind wenn es zur
quarantäne oder wechsel modellen kommt
die kommen ja wirklich nur in
homöopathischen dosen in den schulen und
familien an und auch bei den ländern ist
ja keine klare linie zu erkennen maske
auf in berlin maske runter in nrw nach
gefühlten 100 corona gipfeln gibt es
immer noch keine klaren vorgaben das ist
völlig irre wir müssen netz wir müssen
jetzt alles daran setzen die junge
generation die sich noch nicht impfen
lassen kann um jeden preis zu schützen
wir müssen eltern die sorge nehmen dass
ihre kinder in den bildungseinrichtungen
nicht geschützt sind es braucht einen
plan wie wie kitas und schulen pandemie
festgemacht und möglichst offen gehalten
werden können und eine perspektive wie
die sozialen und psychischen folgen der
pandemie bewältigt werden können das ist
jetzt der bundeswehr das ist der job
einer bundesregierung der alten übrigens
ganz genauso wie der neuen machen sie
endlich ihre arbeit vielen dank vielen
dank nicole wolke
[Applaus]
und die nächste rednerin in dieser
debatte ist ulrike bahr sie ist nicht
nur abgeordnete sondern im nicht
bundestags leben auch lehrerin
[Musik]
frau präsidentin liebe kollegen und
kolleginnen wenn wir ganz sogar
aufgehört haben kinder zu sein dann sind
wir schon tot das sind die worte des
deutschen schriftstellers michael ende
des autors der unendlichen geschichte
die frage wann kinder wieder kinder sein
dürfen beschäftigt mich und ist einer
der gründe warum wir hier debattieren
denn kinder hatten in der tat in den
vergangenen 18 monaten nur sehr wenige
möglichkeiten kind zu sein und kinder
wurden zu hause isoliert kinder können
nicht richtig lernen kinder dürften
nicht mehr kind seien kurz umgehen wir
sind seit beginn der pandemie sie haben
gelitten und zwar sehr
sowie dafür waren vor allem die folgen
der schul und kita schließungen aber die
flächen deckende schließung von schulen
und kitas wird zukünftig keine option
mehr sein auch nicht bei dramatischen
infektionsgeschehen nur dann wenn es in
einer einrichtung ein akutes
ausbruchsgeschehen gibt welches nicht
unter kontrolle zu bekommen ist kann
eine schule oder eine kita vorübergehend
geschlossen werden so sieht ist der neue
gesetzentwurf zum infektionsschutzgesetz
vor
[Applaus]
wenn wir eines aus unternehmen gelernt
haben dann dass entdecken die schul und
kita schließungen nicht erste mittel der
wahl sein können um diese pandemie zu
besiegen der preis dafür ist zu hoch als
ehemalige lehrerin weiß ich wenn wir den
kindern die schule wegnehmen richten wir
schäden an die nur schwer zu reparieren
sind und es ist mittlerweile erwiesen
dass es zahllose kinder mit psychischen
problemen gibt die auch die schließungen
zurückzuführen sind unsere
geschäftsführende
bundesfamilienministerin christine
lambrecht brachte es auf den punkt
schulen und kitas müssen offen bleiben
damit psychische belastungen einsamkeit
bewegungsmangel und lernen rückstände
sich nicht weiter vergrößern aber es
sieht aber
es sind nicht nur die kinder die unter
folgen der schließungen leyen auch das
unverständnis der eltern steigt die
kritik der eltern wendet sich dabei
nicht gegen die korona maßnahmen sie
richtet sich vielmehr dagegen dass
kinder und jugendliche
unverhältnismäßig benachteiligt werden
und auch kinder als die schlagen alarm
kinder sind keine infektions treiber die
am montag veröffentlichte studie der
kultusministerkonferenz wird noch
konkrete
kinder sind nicht die die in erster
linie dass wir so breiten aber sie
leiden eindeutig am meisten und waren
frank von mir von dem wir fängt man
endlich an darauf zu hören in sidenten
bei kindern und erwachsenen werden sehr
verschieden wahrgenommen aus drei
gründen bedarf es bei der insolvenz bei
kindern und jugendlichen eine erklärung
erstens
kinder und jugendliche werden sehr
selten schwer krank schon alleine aus
diesem grund hat die inzidenz völlig
andere auswirkungen als bei erwachsenen
zweiten kinder und jugendliche werden
regelmäßig in kitas und schulen getestet
es gibt in deutschland keine gruppe die
systematisch besser erfasst wird und
drittens ungeimpfte erwachsene lehnen
oftmals nicht nur die impfung sondern
auch die korona maßnahmen ab einen tick
zu meiner ganz rechten seite reicht für
diese erkenntnis völlig aus ungeimpfte
kinder hingegen halten sich meist an die
vorgaben darum kann eine flächendeckende
schließung von kitas und schulen auch
bei höheren instanzen keine option mehr
sein es gibt nur eine möglichkeit aus
der pandemie impfen impfen impfen die
erwachsenen und die jugendlichen der weg
in die normalität wird nur lang aber wir
haben es selbst die werkzeuge in der
hand um worst case szenarien zu
unterbinden sie heißen mehr tests der
impfungen und endlich wieder eine
konsequente nachverfolgung von
infektionen bis wie ein stabiles niveau
erreicht haben der antrag der
linkspartei zählt allerdings
entschuldigung since werkzeuge auf die
bereits realität sind von schnelltests
über medizinische maßen bis hin zu
angeboten für das personal all das ist
bereits teil des alltags an deutschen
schulen und das mit einem sehr hohen
engagement vor ort und hierzu auch der
appell liebe lehrer/innen und
erzieher/innen an den kitas liebe eltern
der schlüssel und deutschlands schulen
und kitas gut durch den winter zu führen
liegt darin dass sie sich alle impfen
und demnächst auch gut sein lassen nur
so stellen wir wirklich sicher dass wir
nie wieder über dieses thema streiten
müssen das ist der beste schutz für
kinder beenden wir diese unendliche
geschichte um schließungen von kitas und
schulen und geben wir unseren kindern
ihr leben zurück zu haben ist sie sich
auch verdient vielen dank vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen nächste rednerin für die
cdu csu fraktion
kathrin staffler
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident ich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
überraschend tut es mich ja nicht dass
die linksfraktionen die zeit die sie
heute im plenum hat dafür nutzten den
antrag vorzulegen der komplett die
verfassungswirklichkeit im
bildungsföderalismus
ausblendet und zwar konsequent wir
kennen das das man überrascht nicht wir
haben das jetzt vier jahre schon so
gesehen mindestens vier jahre
ich bin mal gespannt was sie machen wenn
die zukünftige links gelbe regierung den
bildungsföderalismus ist so wie es ist
zur unkenntlichkeit aufgeweicht oder
abgeschafft da kommen sich den stress
sie kommen die echten stress dann müssen
sie mal was neues überlegen
auch das mag stimmen ann-sophie lassen
was mich in dem schon verwundert ist
dass grant sie als linksfraktion mehr
tempo bei den schutzmaßnahmen für kinder
und jugendliche fordern da muss jetzt an
der stelle schon einmal nachfragen war
es nicht der freistaat thüringen also
geführt unter einer linksfraktion
regierung die die korona testpflicht im
september an schulen beendet hat und das
tragen von masken im unterricht ab der
fünften klasse einfach wegfallen hat
lassen also anstatt jetzt hier im
bundestag eine scheindebatte zu führen
würde ich sagen sollten es doch viel
lieber mal da ansetzen wo die
verantwortlichkeiten auch liegen
vielleicht hat sie mal mit ihren
parteifreunden thüringen sprechen dass
sie vor ort mehr tempo machen bei da
sind sie nämlich zuständig dafür dass
unsere schulen sichere orte sagt und
abgesehen davon
sind wir uns glaube ich über die
parteigrenzen hinweg einig dass die
aufrechterhaltung von präsenz betrieb an
den schulen natürlich das gebot der
stunde ist ich möchte an der stelle im
übrigen auch mal eine lanze brechen für
unsere kommunalpolitiker vor ort die
versuchen da vor ort alles wirklich
alles dass das gelingt die präsenz an
den schulen ich kenne keinen
verantwortlichen in den gemeinden in
meinem wahlkreis der netzer zeit
stundenlang am tag damit verbringt dass
sie die lage einigermaßen im griff
behalten das heißt mit blick auf die
ausreichende versorgung mit
testmöglichkeiten das organisieren von
betreuungs und lehrkräften zusätzliche
räumlichkeiten und so weiter und so fort
man könnte die liste beliebig fortführen
das ist eine echte mammutaufgabe für
unsere kommunen und deswegen möchte ich
an der stelle einfach mal ein großes
dankeschön sagen an die verantwortlichen
die da sehr umsichtig damit umgehen
und
anstatt dass man den ländern dahin den
notwendigen instrumentenkasten an die
hand gibt dass sie passgenau dass sie
effektiv oft die pandemie reagieren
können schenken die ampel fraktionen mit
ihrem beschluss heute die
nichtverlängerung der epidemischen lage
von nationaler tragweite die länder
genau in diesen handlungsoptionen die
mir bislang eigentlich noch hatten noch
weiter ein ganz konkretes beispiel aus
unserem bereich
ganz konkretes beispiel aus dem bereich
das ist doch aus frappierend die
verfassungsrechtliche zuständigkeit für
den für das luftfilters filter
förderprogramm an den schulen haben wir
in der letzten wahlperiode auf den weg
gebracht die sind zwischen ähnlichkeit
für ein programm das sich auch großer
nachfrage erfreut das sieht einzig und
allein auf der feststellung des
vorliegens der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite
wenn die feststellung so wie es heute
passiert ist jetzt wegfällt dann läuft
das programm zum jahresende aus so sieht
die realität aus
und das mitten in einer zeit in der so
mancher landkreisen inzidenz von über
1000 auf fast das ist doch verrückt
machen auf der einen seite groß rund
rund einen schulschließungen wollen
unbedingt verhindern und auf der anderen
seite in kauf nehmen das so wichtige
förderprogramme einfach wegfallen als
oppositionspartei müsste ich mich
eigentlich freuen
in der künftigen regierung solche
wirklich peinlichen handwerklichen
fehler passieren aber ich kann mich
nicht vor allem liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn die fehler zu lasten
unserer kinder gehen die redezeit ist
zuende paten liegen ja wollten
insofern halte ich das was da heute
passiert ist in der jetzigen situation
für absolut absurd ist leider ein
vorgeschmack auf das was uns in den
nächsten jahren unter ihrer regierung
erwarten wird eine verantwortungslose
politik zu lasten unserer kinder schade
man könnte es besser machen
will dann frau staffler
kai gehring wird als nächstes für
bündnis 90 die grünen sprechen und wenn
er nicht hier im bundestag ist dann ist
er auch in den koalitionsgesprächen
aktiv da ist der teil der arbeitsgruppe
für wissenschaft hochschule forschung
und innovation genauso wie übrigens der
redner nach innen jens brandenburg
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen im letzten jahr haben kinder
und jugendliche einen ziemlichen
zickzackkurs bei der pandemie bekämpfung
mitmachen müssen wir alle stehen als
politisch verantwortliche in der pflicht
kindern und jugendlichen
bildungschancen und teilhabe zu
ermöglichen
kinder und jugendliche haben ein recht
auf gesundheit und sie haben ein recht
auf bildung und dieses recht auf bildung
hat besonders gelitten und das ändern
wir jetzt
kinder jugendliche eltern haben die
hauptlast der schul lockt bei uns
getragen die erzieherinnen und
lehrkräfte sind über sich
hinausgewachsen und da können wir nur
danke sagen
kinder und jugendliche waren in der hand
die krise hoch solidarisch und müssen
nun mit ansehen wie sich manche
erwachsene rücksichtslos vergnügen in
geschlossenen räumen karneval feiern
oder dicht gedrängt in fußballstadien
stehen solidarität ist in der pandemie
aber keine einbahnstraße kinder und
jugendliche und ihre förderung gehören
jetzt endlich in den mittelpunkt
ein ende der pandemie ist nicht in sicht
darum sollen länder und kommunen masken
pflicht anordnen können abstandsgebot
verhängen luft filtern nachrüsten
wechsel unterricht anbieten zur
gefahrenabwehr notfalls einzelne klassen
oder sogar auch schulen vorübergehend
schließen dürfen aber ein pauschaler
lockdown und flächendeckend bundesweit
von jetzt auf gleich alle
bildungseinrichtungen dicht zu machen
dass es mit dem recht auf bildung nicht
mehr vereinbar
denn
geschlossene schulen bedeuten bildungs
verluste für kinder und jugendliche
geschlossene schulen schaden besonders
kids mit ohnehin geringen
bildungschancen hinzu kommen
psychosoziale belastungen und deswegen
müssen und wollen wir schulschließungen
deutlich sorgfältiger und
verhältnismäßiger angehen als es die
vorgängerin getan hat
wir wollen gute bildung aber sicher und
das müssen wir im ganzen land endlich
besser hinkriegen in vielen ländern nach
sehr langen zögern auch vom bund gibt es
programme um klassenräume mit
luftfiltern auszustatten doch
europäische vorgaben blockieren dass sie
schnell vor ort den schülerinnen und
schülern zugute kommen selbst private
initiativen helfen nicht bei mir im
ruhrgebiet wollten eltern luftfilter
privatspenden und in der schule für ihre
kids aufstellen das nrw bauministerium
sagte schropp nein denn zitat des
könnten geräte gekauft werden die nicht
gut genug sind statt blockaden und hoch
bürokratische antragsverfahren brauchen
wir mehr agilität und mehr pragmatismus
in der umsetzung
unsere aufgaben als
bundestagsabgeordneter ist doch jetzt
die nachlässigkeit der noch amtierenden
regierung zu korrigieren und den ländern
viel stärker unter die arme zu greifen
damit programme endlich fliegen und
damit programme endlich stärker ans
laufen kommen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen impfen impfen impfen dass es
immer noch das beste mittel um die
pandemie beherrschbar zu machen und die
imf logistik muss jetzt deutlich
schneller wieder hochgefahren werden und
zwar planmäßig und zackig für die erst-
bis zu den dritt impfungen und in kürze
dann auch für die impfung der unter
zwölfjährigen in meiner kindheit waren
impfungen gegen kinderkrankheiten ein
selbstverständliches gruppen event in
kitas und schulen und diese
selbstverständlichkeit wünsche ich mir
für heute zurück
impfstoffe sind meisterstücke der
wissenschaft zivilisatorischer
fortschritt und sie retten menschenleben
für mich ist es daher unerträglich wenn
einzelne erzieherinnen und lehrkräfte
die impfung verweigern und so in kauf
nehmen die gesundheit auch ihrer
schutzbefohlenen zu gefährden darum
unser appell lassen sie sich endlich
impfen der beste schutz für noch
ungeimpfte kinder sind geimpfte
erwachsene
und auch die berufsverbände und
gewerkschaften bitte ich wirken sie auf
ihre mitglieder stärker ein das risiko
das virus zu übertragen oder daran zu
erkranken ist durch die impfung deutlich
vermindert darum ist es folgerichtig
eine impfpflicht für einzelne
berufsgruppen ins auge zu fassen in
verantwortung gegenüber kindern und zum
selbstschutz und im übrigen auch zur
befriedung in den einzelnen
einrichtungen
impfen ist gelebte solidarität damit
nicht mehr kinder und jugendliche die
hauptlast zu tragen haben und sie
endlich alle unterstützung bekommen beim
nachholen und aufholen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
doktor jens brandenburg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die monatelange
und flächendeckenden schulschließungen
haben in der jungen generation
verheerende schäden hinterlassen ein
drittel der jungen schüler und
schülerinnen hat sehr starke psychische
auffälligkeiten im schul lockdown
gezeigt sie lebten oftmals unter
sozialer isolation und unter
bewegungsmangel viele von ihnen haben
den anschluss im unterricht völlig
verloren hat man oftmals keinen
geregelten tagesablauf und auch keine
motivation überhaupt noch zu lernen ob
und inwiefern unterricht überhaupt
stattgefunden hat hängen sehr stark von
der jeweiligen schule der lehrkraft und
auch dem elternhaus ab denn nicht jeder
hat zu hause ein eigenes zimmer in das
man sich zum lernen zurückziehen kann
die nötige technische ausstattung für
digitalen unterricht oder auch ein
soziales umfeld das jeden morgen aufs
neue zum lernen motiviert kinder und
jugendliche haben ein recht auf bildung
und der staat hat eine pflicht zu
unterrichten dieser pflicht ist der
deutschen staaten in den letzten monaten
nicht ausreichend gerecht geworden
deshalb ist es richtig dass die drei
fraktionen der ampel parteien heute
vormittag das instrument der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
ersetzt haben denn auch in pandemie
zeiten darf es nie wieder zu einer
flächendeckenden schulschließung kommen
gemeinsam mit spd und grünen haben wir
freie demokraten heute ein neues kapitel
der pandemie politik eröffnet denn über
die hälfte der intensivbetten sind
momentan mit menschen älter als 70 jahre
belegt der anteil der kinder und
jugendlichen auf den intensivstationen
ist sehr sehr gering sie können sich
zwar infizieren haben aber in aller
regel sehr milde verläufe die
eigentlichen risikogruppen sind also
menschen mit vorerkrankungen und
insbesondere die ältere generation und
trotzdem hat die bisherige regierung
insbesondere die jugend in die soziale
isolation geschickt bis heute wird doch
an den schulen sehr viel engmaschiger
auf kroner getestet als in den alten und
pflegeheimen also dort im direkten
umfeld derjenigen die am meisten von
corona bedroht sind und das werden wir
ändern die zeit haften der schmerzhaften
placebo politik wie sind vorbei wir
setzen auch wirksame maßnahmen in der
ampel die die älteren schützen und die
jungen nicht alleine lassen und
natürlich können auch kinder und
jugendliche das virus weiter geben keine
frage was ist also zu tun um
infektionsketten auch an den schulen
besser zu durchbrechen das programm die
habens fdp seit ich in den letzten
jahren immer wieder gefordert mobile
luftfilter haben sie seitens der
unionsfraktion so lange verschleppt dass
die kommunen jetzt aktuell mit massiven
lieferengpässen zu kämpfen haben jetzt
zählt nur noch testen testen testen mit
der gesetzesnovelle von heute vormittag
haben die länder alle möglichkeiten zur
hand weitere auflagen für einen pandemie
gerichten unterrichts zu beschließen die
impfquote ist erfreulicherweise bei den
lehrkräften auch bei erziehern und
erzieherinnen mit etwa 90 prozent
bereits sehr hoch nicht aber bei den
jugendlichen ab zwölf jahren für dieses
ja auch seitens der stiko eine
offizielle impfempfehlung gibt da liegt
sie bundesweit bei etwa 45 prozent da
ist viel luft nach oben und das
musterland schleswig holstein zeigt wie
das gelingen kann setzen wir also
bundesweit auch niedrigschwellige
angebote für jugendliche auch an den
schulen
und schulen sind ja in dieser pandemie
nicht der infektions treiber im
gegenteil mit den regelmäßigen tests
fragen sie ganz wesentlich zur
frühzeitigen erkennung von
infektionsketten bei die junge
generation die darf jetzt nicht erneut
zum opfer zum leidtragenden einer
falschen politik werden und deshalb
haben wir gemeinsam mit spd und grünen
science der freien demokraten diesen
politikwechsel eingeleitet in der
pandemie politik ein wechsel der endlich
das recht auf bildung achtet die
psychische gesundheit junger menschen
genau so ernst nimmt wie ihre
körperliche gesundheit und die
risikogruppen insbesondere die ältere
generation endlich wirksam schützt sie
haben dass seitens der unionsfraktion in
den letzten monaten versäumt wie werden
das gemeinsam ändern und deshalb ist
heute ein guter schritt zur bewältigung
dieser pandemie und ein starkes signal
an die junge generation
vielen dank herr jens brandenburg
nächster redner in der debatte über die
vermeidung von schulschließungen
aufgrund der fdp
aufgrund der korona pandemie pardon
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren aber ich muss schon sagen ich bin
etwas überrascht wie viele meiner
vorredner heute hier von diesem puls
medizinische empfehlung abgegeben haben
also
ich habe zwar auch studiert weil sie was
wie studiert haben aber von den meisten
weiß ich dass sie zumindest nicht
medizin studiert haben herr gehring
weniger brandenburg sie auch nicht also
dann wäre ich doch ein bisschen
zurückhaltender mit solchen empfehlung
nicht dass sie dann noch schwierigkeiten
bekommen meine damen und herren der
antrag der linken und den geht es ja
heute hier als ich dann gesehen habe der
macht ist das klingt ja sehr gut kita
und schule schließung verhindern genau
das wollen wir auch lesen wir doch mal
was da drin steht und es ging ja auch
richtig los da beschreiben sie die
konsequenzen der maßnahmen nicht der
pandemie und des virus sondern das haben
wir auch alle redner heute eingeräumt
schülerinnen und schüler die kinder
haben vor allen dingen gelitten unter
den konsequenzen der maßnahmen die sie
miteinander hier eingeführt haben und an
dem sie viel zu lange festgehalten haben
ihre lernt wurde ist so flach dass kann
man auch alles viel eher verstehen wir
waren die erste fraktion die gesagt hat
wir müssen die schulen vorsorglich
schließen aber nur für einen kurzen
zeitraum weil wir wussten nicht wie
gefährlich dieses virus sein könnte für
kinder und jugendliche die anderen
länder um uns herum hatten schon alle
die schulen geschlossen sie haben
geschlafen und sie haben dann
überreagiert und wir waren natürlich
auch die erste fraktion die gesehen hat
für kinder und jugendliche ist dieses
virus gar nicht besonders gefährlich
deshalb haben wir gefordert die schulen
wieder aufzumachen weil wir erkannt
haben was sie mit ihren maßnahmen
anrichten und wenigstens haben sie das
heute eingeräumt sie sollten sich bei
den schülern und kindern entschuldigen
für das was ihnen angetan haben
meine damen und herren wie gesagt kinder
sind nicht oder nur zum glück nur selten
opfer des virus aber sie sind opfer
ihrer maßnahmen geworden und dieser
antrag der linken der ronja die
schulschließung weiter ein als optionen
sie wollen sie ja gar nicht ausräumen
insofern meine damen und herren ist auch
dieser antrag letztlich bei genauerer
betrachtung nur eine mogelpackung er
bringt uns nicht weiter meine damen und
herren es
stellt sich natürlich auch noch das
wurde schon angesprochen die frage der
zuständigkeit vieles was sie beschreiben
gehört ja in dem bereich der länder nun
haben wir schon in der letzten
legislaturperiode gesehen dass sich hier
eine neue allianz gebildet hat zur
schleifung der föderalen strukturen
unseres grundgesetzes demnach gehört ja
bildung wie kultur eindeutig in den
länder bereich das wollten sie
abschaffen am ende ist sogar die cdu
hier halbwegs umgekippt der kollege
japans gehört in der richtung
argumentiert ich hoffe dass die cdu
jetzt in der opposition gemeinsam mit
uns wieder auf den pfad der tugend
zurück findet ich sage treten sie mit
uns gemeinsam für das umgesetzt stellen
sie sich vor den
realismus und hören sie auf gemeinsam
mit den rot geld gelb-grünen bildungs
sozialisten die strukturen unserer
verfassung ins wanken zu bringen der
föderalismus hat sich bewährt wir
sollten ihn beibehalten und
zentralismus wie werden hier aus der ddr
vielleicht noch kennen den brauchen wir
nicht meine damen und herren
dankeschön woche freundin
nächste rednerin in dieser debatte ist
jessica rosenthal von der spd-fraktion
freuen wir uns ich freue mich auf jeden
fall und ich hoffe sie sich auch auf die
erste rede der kollegin jessica
rosenthal für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es wurde jetzt mehrfach deutlich gesagt
diese pandemie hat nicht nur
menschenleben gekostet
sondern sie hat chancen gekostet und ich
kann ihnen sagen dass eine lehrerin die
in der pandemie unterrichtet hat ich
habe diese chancen durch meine finger
rinnen sehen ich saß im online
unterricht und auf der anderen seite saß
seine inklusions kind die mutter der
deutschen sprache nicht mächtig hat
alles gegeben um diesen kind zu helfen
ich habe es fünf mal probiert diese
hilflosigkeit die ich selber gespürt
habe werde ich niemals vergessen
und ich glaube sie zeigt sehr deutlich
was die kolleginnen und kollegen die in
den schulen stehen und das versucht
haben was die erzieherin was alle in den
bildungseinrichtungen jeden tag
geleistet haben und jeden tag leisten
und ich finde es ist zeit sie sagen
dankeschön immer wieder zu sagen danke
schön dass ihr euch rein
ich möchte ab
eine bitte nicht vergessen die sich
genauso bein gehangen hat und das hört
ihr das beispiel gezeigt auch die eltern
haben alles gegeben und ja vor allem
auch die mütter die in dieser
doppelbelastung so viel gestimmt haben
und das war am ende keine
selbstverständlichkeit das will ich mal
so klar sagen es war auf abruf voll und
uns gebührt diesem engagement unser
tiefster respekt
und ich will
meine erfahrungen sind hier keine
subjektiven eindruck kommen sondern
meine erfahrungen sind evident und sind
die erfahrung und all meiner kolleginnen
und kollegen wenn sich die lernzeit
halbiert hat wenn 90 prozent meiner
kolleginnen und kollegen sagen die
soziale ungerechtigkeit hat sich
verstärkt dann muss man doch sagen dass
zeigt sich hier und wen wundert es am
ende auch zwei bis drei wenn sich zwei
bis drei geschwister ein zimmer teilen
dann kann man nicht vernünftig lernen
und deshalb sage ich auch klar wer
deutschland zum chancen land machen will
dann muss auch die wohnungskrise
bekämpfen der muss auch dafür sorgen
dass bildungs durchlässigkeit da ist das
vernünftige ausstattung da ist
dieses haus hat natürlich auch eine ganz
konkrete verantwortung in dieser
pandemie und wir müssen kindern und
jungen menschen antworten geben darauf
wie ihr recht auf bildung gewahrt werden
kann und deshalb ist das
infektionsschutzgesetz der kollege hat
es gerade nochmal dargestellt genau der
richtige schritt gewesen
und ich sage ihnen mal ganz klar
wie perfide sie ausgerechnet das wohl
von kindern und jugendlichen hier vor
schützen um ihre
wirklich
menschenverachtenden und extrem
kritischen lügen zu rechtfertigen das
muss ich etwas sagen dass mit jungen
menschen so was von überhaupt nicht
gerecht wir müssen einfach klar sagen
das einzige was diese kinder schützt das
ist dass wir uns alle impfen lassen also
stehen sie endlich dazu wir müssten uns
impfen lassen und genau das steht das
fest
für die kinder sicher und es findest du
deshalb auch richtig dass wir jetzt
sagen keine flächendeckenden
schulschließungen und ja ich sage auch
es ist richtig dass wir vor allem die
betriebe auch in die pflicht nehmen dass
wir jetzt sagen es muss 3g gelten in den
betrieben wir brauchen der home office
pflicht denn zuerst müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass in den betrieben gegen die
vierte welle an gekämpft wird und wir
müssen gerade darüber auch sicherstellen
dass kinder und jugendliche geschützt
werden also von daher sind wir in der
sache an der stelle glaube ich zusammen
wir haben die maßnahmen schon
beschlossen und jetzt geht es das recht
auf bildung sicherzustellen vielen dank
für deinen jessica rosenthal
damit kommen wir zum letzten redner in
dieser debatte das ist stefan albanien
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hier in dieser
debatte die schulschließungen und kita
schließungen vermieden werden können
grund ist ein antrag der linksfraktion
vier im deutschen bundestag
letzte redner in dieser debatte aber so
wie es aussieht auch in der debatte
heute stephan albani für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
unser jede frau präsidentin meine
kolleginnen und kollegen ich glaube wir
sind uns fast alle einig impfen impfen
schulen nicht schließen die
bildungschancen unserer kinder reiten
ist ein ziel das wir alle gemeinsam
verfolgen das ist völlig logisch und
insofern war ich am dienstag als sich
die information bekam hier soll eine
solche debatte aufgesetzt werden ganz
gespannt weil ich gedacht wow da wird
sie zu schreiben zum einen fallen sind
stehen denen wir alle noch überhaupt
nicht bedacht haben der jetzt genau in
dieser parlamentarischer arbeit uns alle
wie so eine art erweckungserlebnis
auf dem tisch lag hatte ich eine gewisse
ernüchterung
die analyse fraglos korrekte situation
mündet in drei forderungen die der
beginnende bundestag fordert die
bundesregierung auf und jetzt kommt
gemeinsam mit den ländern und das zeigt
wieder mal einen fehler einsatz linker
bildungspolitik da wo sie etwas ändern
können wo sie etwas ändern wollen können
sie es nicht und da wo sie es können
wollen sie es nicht das hat schon meine
kollegin frau tiemann letzten legislatur
in vielen debatten schier zur
verzweiflung gebracht und deswegen ein
kleiner merksatz schulen liegen in der
verantwortung der länder punkt das ist
nun mal so das können wir hier auch
nicht ändern
[Applaus]
jetzt sollen sie aber mal zum hörtest
gehen da war was
und dann nutzt es auch nichts sich
hinzustellen wie sie es jetzt gerade tun
frau holte und wie ein struwwelpeter zu
sagen ich will das aber und die menschen
interessiert das alles gar nicht mehr an
dieser stelle bedeutet dass letzten
endes den realitäten ins auge zu schauen
und dann ist es nämlich unsere aufgabe
hier von seiten des bundes vorschläge
angebote und unterstützungen für die
länder auf den weg zu bringen und da
haben wir immer nicht fertig ist in der
letzten legislatur gebracht angefangen
von den sehr intensiven gesprächen über
gepolte google tests die im ausland sich
als sehr positiv erwiesen haben und auf
diese art und weise schulschließung
verhindern könnten haben wir dieses
entsprechend angeboten auch pohl pcr
test auf looki test basis sind letzten
endes von den beiden ministerium in den
ländern angeboten und ein land wie
nordrhein westfalen oder laschet und
wüst haben dieses entsprechend auch
flächendeckend zur anwendung gebracht
andere länder winken ab
sohn insofern wieder der kleine merksatz
schulen liegen der verantwortung der
länder punkt
müssen wir auch getan haben und was aus
meiner sicht sehr weit ging war eine s3
leitlinie des wmf zum maßnahmen von
prävention und kontrolle des der
übertragung an schulen das war eine
große broschüren der wir alle maßnahmen
aufgelistet haben die an schulen
notwendig und machbar sind auf sortiert
bzw klassifiziert nach ihren effekten et
cetera et cetera als grundlage also die
länder hatten alle möglichkeiten hier
aus diesem katalog gleich eine speise
deine speiseplan auszusuchen was sie für
richtig halten also insofern genau das
ist aus meiner sicht die aufgabe des
bundes jenseits einer koordinierung aber
sich vorzustellen wie in ihrem antrag
wir sagen nein jetzt gehen wir ihnen die
länder und machen das mal so ist einfach
eine föderalismus vorbei gedacht
insofern endig mit dem merksatz sie
ahnen es und ich hoffe als
bildungspolitiker auf effekt schulen
liegen in der verantwortung der länder
punkt und noch mal zu ihrem problem
wenn sie etwas ändern wollen können sie
es nicht und wenn sie es können wollen
sie es nicht und damit wären wir in
thüringen
hier hat einen minister an dieser stelle
möglichkeiten gehabt alles möglich zu
machen und er verantwortet lehrermangel
und schleppende umsetzung in der
digitalisierung also bitte sortieren sie
das projekt unsere aufgabe ist an dieser
stelle klar auf seiten des bundes und
dann würde auch so ein antrag nicht mehr
notwendig sein dank herr kollege albani
damit schließe ich die aussprache
bekommst du und die debatte über die
vermeidung von schulschließungen ist
damit hier beendet claudia roth die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin hartes jahr
angekündigt es hier war nicht nur der
letzte redner in dieser debatte sondern
auch